[Music]
tell me was it just ill health that made
you do what you did B and
what all the art of futility of
everything I see it even in
flowers hear it in
music all life aimless without me what
do you want to meaning
for life is a desire not a meaning
desire is the theme of all life it's
what makes a rose want to be Al to grow
like that The Rock want to contain
itself and remain like
that yes life could be wonderful your
all it needs is courage
[Music]
imagination
I what is to fight for
everything so enough to be live suffer
enjoy life for life is a beautiful
magnificent thing even to a Chelly
[Music]
fish if something just doesn't haveit de
let life life life life think of the
power that's in the universe moving the
Earth growing the trees and that's the
same power within you if you'll only
have courage and the will to use it
[Music]
every
life is a desire not meaning desire is
the theme of all life what makes R want
to be a
roow the rock to contain itself remain
[Music]